avec thierry coville chercheur à l'iris
et spécialiste de l'iran bonsoir thierry
coville
enfin on l'a vu beaucoup de candidatures
ont été disqualifiés pour ces élections
législatives est ce que cet inédit
puisque maintenant on se retrouve avec
un face à face aux conservateurs
ultraconservateur non non c'est pas du
tout une i10 et une vieille pratique du
conseil des gardiens de la constitution
qui est un organisme en iran que le
pouvoir de sélectionner les candidats
aux élections législatives et
présidentielle et c'est pas nouveau
par contre ce qui est un peu ce qui est
nouveau on va dire c'est l'ampleur de
disqualification là on a on avait dit
des milliers de candidats pour 4,90
député de l'ancien parlement n'ont même
pas pu se représenter
des députés comme ali motahari même des
têtes un conservateur un peu critique
vers toutes les voix un peu critique
vis-à-vis on va dire du pouvoir où les
conservateurs modérés ou les
réformateurs ont vraiment été écartée
donc c'est vrai que là haut niveau de
disqualification et quasiment sans
précédent
alors pour quelle raison et est ce que
c'est le contexte actuel qui selon moi
je suis pas dans la tête des blacks
c'est décidé on va dire au plus haut
niveau je pense que le calcul qui est
fait on va dire chez le guide ali
khamenei et chez les ultras c'est que
ils veulent dans une situation de crise
et de quasi guerre avec les états unis
ils veulent contrôler tous les pouvoirs
en iran donc manifestement alors ils se
sont également dit qu'avec la crise
économique dont vous venez de parler de
toute façon les modérés n'avait pas
grande chance n'est pas beaucoup de
chances de gagner mais il voulait
prendre aucun risque donc manifestement
les ultras comme on les appelle en iran
vole contrôler tous les pouvoirs donc
déjà évolué contrôler le parlement et du
coût conséquent si une faible
participation attendue puisque c'est en
cours de déploiement mais oui alors là
c'est je trouve ça intéressant parce que
du côté de notamment des grandes villes
comme téhéran s'était vraiment je trouve
ça donne une idée quand même se montre
aussi à quel point la classe moyenne
urbaine en iran on va dire à un niveau
de maturité politique est vive sur la
grande discussion en iran c'est est ce
qu'on va voter ou pas etc
et manifestement pourtant il ya une
sorte de
comment dire des injonctions notamment
des ultras qu'on dit qu'on dit voilà
c'est un devoir patriotique fasse
effectivement ces tensions vis-à-vis de
l'étranger vous devez aller voter et la
réponse de la classe moyenne urbaine
c'est non et dans ces conditions là vous
avez disqualifié quasiment tous les
candidats pour lesquels on voulait
goûter dont ils sont pas allés voter
donc il ya pas de recentrage
patriotiques on aurait pu attendre
justement dans un contexte de situation
difficile intérieure mais est sous
l'ailé ça n'empêche pas les iraniens des
très nationaliste et puis quand ils sont
sortis en masse par exemple pour
célébrer l'enterrement de du général sur
les manies donc ils sont très
nationalistes par contre là c'est un
message qui font passer aux autorités en
disant non ces disqualifications sont
cons lire ne sont pas normales donc on
répond pas n'ont pas voté alors
effectivement il ya un mécontentement
également plus globale par rapport à la
crise économique par rapport également à
le fait que vous savez quand l'iran a
battu le fin les passe d'aaron tabac tue
le boeing craignant il ya un grand
mécontentement dans la population ce que
les autorités augmenté pendant trois
mois donc cette classe moyenne urbaine
et répondent ils en ont mais sait on est
nationaliste mais là on va pas se
déplacer on va pas aller voter dans ces
conditions parmi les candidats en tête
il y à un ancien gardien de la
révolution l'ancien maire de téhéran
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça implique
qu'ils savaient qui est cet homme là
annie beau fils
si vous voulez c'est dans là il était
candidat effectivement aux élections
présidentielles c'est un voit très bien
si vous laissez les durs en fait ce
qu'on appelle les ultras effectivement
qu'ils veulent vraiment gagner le
parlement et donc sa annoncent que
veulent vraiment les ultras c'est
vraiment avoir qu'une seule voie en iran
et est ce qu'on peut craindre ces autres
cas annoncés plus tôt en iran plutôt
radicale à l'extérieur c'est très
clairement il ya un lien entre politique
intérieure politique extérieure le fait
que les durs foulée les dieux sur une
logique période de répression par
rapport aux mouvements sociaux et et de
ne plus négocier l'accord de vienne est
alors il faut attendre parce que l'iran
comme intérêt aussi à rester dans
l'accord mais de celle et dur il ya
beaucoup de voix qui sont plutôt
favorables
effectivement une sortie de l'accord
avec 22 points de sortie du tmp donc ce
que je veux dire c'est le fait que les
durs prennent le pouvoir sur tille
pouvoir en iran sa annonce pains me rend
très facile et plus c'est à dire
s'annonce plutôt en iran radical sur le
plan de sa politique étrangère
conséquence pour un à sannois yanick et
8 termine son mandat en 2021 à sannois
nick a été présenté comme un modéré
comment est ce que le pouvoir va se
jouer entre d une assemblée durée un
président un peu plus modéré ça annonce
à une femme demande à compliqué pour lui
parce qu'il est
il était déjà sous le feu des critiques
des ultras mais qu'ils ne contrôlaient
pas encore le parlement avec un nul des
ultras qui contrôle qui contrôle le
parlement
ils vont ils vont faire de feu de tout
bois contre lui par contre on voit très
bien que les ultras n'ont pas intérêt il
y avait beaucoup de discussions franches
et ultra pour demander la démission
avoir une procédure d impeachment pour
hassan rohani voit très bien qu'ils ont
aussi intérêt à le mettre en premier
plan le poste de président parce que
quelque part ils ont une bonne route les
ultras ils sont là le critiquer mais il
ya beaucoup de journées en quissac qui
ferait pas beaucoup mieux à sa place
donc ils ont un terrain qui reste en
place
est ce que préfèrent les ultras c'est la
prochaine élection présidentielle de
2021 et hassan rohani qui lui avait misé
1 sur la signature de cet accord de
vienne pour redonner de la prospérité au
pays c'est terminé ça va être très une
période très difficile économiquement
pour on voit aussi aux américaines qui
ont été dépassées on voit aussi les
conséquences
enfin je suis pas le moi je les dis
depuis le début je suis pas le seul à
dire le conséquences de cette politique
américaine ils ont complètement
déligitimer les modérés qui avait tout
misé droit nitoo oui derrière cet accord
et dire aux promettre aux iraniens grâce
à cet accord vous à voir l'économie va
repartir
ben justement à cause de la politique
américaine
cette politique n'a pas marché et c'est
cette partie des modérés complètement
délégitimer est il maintenant les
américains se retrouvent en face des
radicaux et donc la cndh est
effectivement une des conséquences de
cette politique et annick ont voulu
sortir de l'accord en mai 2018 merci
beaucoup thierry coville d'avoir répondu
à nos questions aussi rester le plus